bogdanovic miss it good interior defense  and  he will look for the first score duncan  robinson pull up three  and then a perfect way to restart the  nba and that accounts for about 40  points per game from this year's kings  jimmy butler nice pitch robinson's wide  open in the corner  oh two in a row here's butler getting  past bazemore  the ball movement's been crisp there's  duncan kaboom  uh part two of the training camp in  orlando pick and roll dragach  sends it out oh look who's wide open  kaboom  that's the last man you want to leave  that open  four trays for duncan robinson and five  tries  hard to think about the heat without  those two yeah too critical critical  guys i mean when you look at the  starting lineup uh  two integral pieces look at duncan  knocking down another trump those guys  will be  a welcome addition back to the hardwood